Land und Brecht
[Musik]
schönen guten Morgen Richard guten
Morgen Markus hoffe es geht dir gut ja
du genießt den Sommer ich genieße den
Sommer in vollen Zügen
Richard ich wollte mit dir über was
sprechen sozusagen einen Teil 2 machen
ich weiß nicht wie es dir gegangen ist
ich habe wahnsinnig viele Reaktionen
bekommen auf unseren Austausch zum Thema
AFD ja gehen dir auch so gegen mir
genauso und was sagen die Leute also am
häufigsten höre ich eigentlich dass die
Menschen das gut finden dass wir ein
fairen Umgang damit mit dem Thema machen
also dass wir versuchen es von
verschiedenen Seiten zu sehen von
verschiedenen Perspektiven zu
analysieren dass wir nicht
holzschnittartig oder schablonenhaft
damit umgehen und ich glaube das spricht
viele Menschen aus dem Herzen mal ganz
egal ob Sie mit der Partei
sympathisieren oder ob sie die Partei
ganz furchtbar finden aber dass man sich
mit einer Partei die von nach Umfragen
jedenfalls von einem Fünftel der
Bevölkerung gewählt wurde dass man sich
damit nicht einfach macht sondern dass
man sich mit dem Phänomen in der
Vielfalt und in auch in der
Widersprüchlichkeit auseinandersetzt ich
glaube das hat vielen Menschen gefallen
weil sie meinen das kommt sonst selten
vor also wenn man sich die Umfragen
anschaut und dann versteht man auch und
woher dieses Interesse kommt im Moment
liegen die bundesweit bei 21 Prozent das
ist der eine Befund der andere ist nur
noch vier Punkte hinter der Union die
Union liegt gerade bei 25,5% du
erinnerst dich Friedrich Merzig
angetreten mit dem Versprechen ich werde
die AFD halbieren halbiert die AFD die
CDU genau das ist das was was Herr
kropalla dann daraus macht aber selbst
wenn es keine Halbierung ist also genau
tatsache ist dass die Tatsache das
Friedrich Merz als konservativer CDU
Mann bekannt ist nichts an der Tatsache
geändert hat dass die AFD weiterhin
aufsteigt ja genau das ist eine Punkt in
Thüringen mittlerweile weil weit über
30% und ich habe in den Reaktion das war
sehr interessant gestern auch noch mal
mit jemandem darüber gesprochen einem
unserer Sendung und sie sagte ich würde
es nicht machen ich würde nicht über die
AFD sprechen ich würde den keine
Plattform geben und ich hätte das auch
wissenschaftlich sehr gut fundiert
begründet kluge Frau die sagte weißt du
wenn man diesen Leuten prinzipiell eine
Bühne gibt und es ist völlig egal ob man
sie argumentativ entlarvt oder nicht
dann haben sie trotzdem am Ende immer
gewonnen und ich musste an ein sehr
bekanntes Zitat von Erik kantonard
denken den du natürlich auch kennst das
große Fußballspieler von Manchester
United genau
richtig ein großer Versuch
davor genau der mal gesagt haben sollen
mit Rassisten zu debattieren ist wie mit
einer Taube Schacht zu spielen ja es ist
egal wie gut du bist am Ende wird die
Taube alle Figuren vom Spielfeld werfen
auf das brettkacken und herum stolzieren
als hätte sie gewonnen ja und zu sagen
der Befund zu sagen irgendwie der Fehler
ist es sich auf das Spiel überhaupt
einzulassen ja und ich habe lange
darüber
wenn der Satz stimmen würde um an sagen
würde die 21 Prozent die jetzt in den
Umfragen angeben AFD wählen zu wollen
wären Rassisten dann würde das zutreffen
und dann würde ich auch der Dame die du
da zitierst das Recht geben aber das ist
erstmal eine ziemlich harte
Unterstellung also zu behaupten dass
alle afd-wähler Rassisten sind also wir
da 21 Prozent Tendenz steigend Rassisten
in diesem Land haben das halte ich
erstmal für eine gewagte Prothese nicht
das ist ehrlich gesagt seine AFD gibt
ja genau das funktioniert nicht und
ansonsten wäre das Argumenten denen eine
Plattform geben wird er nicht mehr
funktionieren also wenn ich jetzt sage
das sind Nazis ja oder ich sage
Rassisten dann verstehe ich den darf man
keine Plattform geben das verstehe ich
aber wenn man aber sagt das sind zum
großen Teil Leute die aus welchen
Gründen auch immer unzufrieden mit der
Regierungspolitik sind oder so eine
Haltung haben das müsste jetzt ein ganz
neuer für jeden oder es geht nicht
weiter wie bisher und so weiter müssen
sie ja nicht allesamt Rassisten sein und
wenn es so ist dann kann ich nicht sagen
mit denen reden wir nicht weil das ist
eine demokratischen Rechtsstaat passt
das nicht ich kann nicht sagen wir
grenzen eine Partei komplett aus außer
ich weise eben nach dass sie tatsächlich
nur aus Nazis und Rassisten besteht aber
das ist eben eine gewagte Spekulation ja
ehrlich gesagt das ist Quatsch also 21
Prozent der Bevölkerung dieses Landes zu
unterstellen sie seinen Rassisten
rechtsradikale gar Nazis ja finde ich
ganz schwierig und mich in diesen Tagen
noch mal klar geworden wie sehr man auch
gerade in diesen Tagen versuchen muss
mit der Sprache wirklich präzise zu sein
ich erinnere mich an den Tweet auch von
von Jan Böhmermann in Richtung Sandra
Maischberger er hat aber viel auch das
Wort Nazis und so weiter und man dir
vorgeworfen man würde dann Nazis eine
Bühne geben ich finde das Wort Nazis
allein schon schwierig wenn du einmal in
Auschwitz Spaß den Birkenau warst wenn
du einmal mit Holocaust Überlebenden
gesprochen hast dann wirst du nie wieder
einfach leichtfertig sagen du bist Nazi
weil das alles verharmlos was Nazis
wirklich wahr ist ja das ist mein Punkt
Tino krupala ist kein Nazi er ist
möglicherweise rechts und rechtsextrem
in seinen Ansichten und möglicherweise
ist auch ein Wolf im Schafspelz kommt
sozusagen daher im gewandt und des
netten handwerkermeisters der von der
Basis kommt der genau weiß wovon er
redet und wurde Leuten zu der Schuh
drückt und vielleicht erzählt er das
dann so im Fernsehen und den Interviews
und eigentlich kriegst du ihn gar nicht
so richtig so fassen und eigentlich ist
er ja fast ein Pazifist weil er gegen
diesen Krieg in der Ukraine ist und so
weiter und das ist ja gar nicht unser
Krieg was müssen wir uns da ein und
Herren im übrigen sie haben auch was
dagegen ist einfach ständig unschuldige
Menschen sterben ja wer wollte dagegen
was sagen das ist doch klar aber genau
relativiert die Verbrechen des Dritten
Reiches lässt der Punkt ja also wenn ich
hingehe und sage dass die 21 Prozent die
hier der AFD wählen alle Nazis sind dann
wird aus jedem der leicht rechts von der
Union steht ein Nazi gemacht genau ja
und damit wäre tatsächlich den braven
Handwerksmeister und so weiter die aus
welchen Gründen auch immer AFD wird weil
er kein weil er keine Wölfe haben will
und kein Windrad ich will da gleich
zurückkommen viel steht nämlich im
Parteiprogramm der AFD ist sehr viel von
12-jährige also wirklich lange lustig
das ist wusste ich jetzt nicht ähm dass
ich jetzt das Bild vom Wolf im Schaft
benutzt habe
eine überdurchschnittlich große Rolle
nein aber es gibt ja viele Motive warum
immer die Partei wählt und die alle
diese Menschen alle kollektiv als Nazis
abzustempeln ist eine Verharmlosung
gegessen was ein Arzt hier ist dieses
genau deswegen Obacht mit der Sprache
sozusagen ich zwei Sachen Richard ich
würde total gerne heute mal mit dir ein
Gedankenexperiment machen und zwar mal
überlegen was wäre wenn also was wäre
wenn da jetzt einer kommen würde einer
der nicht unangenehm und eklig daher
redet einer der nicht in irgendwelchen
Hinterzimmern und dann doch wieder von
irgendjemandem heimlich aufgenommen und
damit überführt widerliche
rassistische rechtsextreme Parolen von
sich gibt und ekelhaftes Zeug erzählt
sondern einer der ganz anders ist der
Smart ist der freundlich ist der jovial
Auftritt der nicht extrem der Herr redet
der immer wieder an den gesunden
Menschenverstand appelliert und der dann
über dies nicht nur rhetorisch
unglaublich gut drauf ist sondern auch
noch optisch was hergegeben
ja genauso gut gebrauchter Jörg Haider
bei jemanden nicht ansieht dass er auch
nach ihnen sehr gebräunt ist ja also die
die Fortsetzung der Bräune siehst du
sozusagen gar nicht unterstellen kann
aber auch nicht aus einer rechten
genau alles denkbar und angenommen
dieser Mann oder auch diese Frau schafft
jetzt langsam den Weg an die Spitze geht
immer weiter immer weiter erst wirst du
irgendwo Minister vielleicht in einem
Landesparlament und dann wirst du
plötzlich irgendwann mal
Ministerpräsident plötzlich bist du
Kanzlerkandidaten plötzlich wirst du
Kanzler was würde dann in diesem Land
passieren wie wie könnte sozusagen so
ein
Kapern der Institutionen wie könnte das
aussehen was würde dann passieren das
ist sehr interessant wenn man sich damit
mal beschäftigt weil es gibt Länder die
so eine Art Blaupause dafür sind
ungarisch und Stichwort aber
Polen genau wo du siehst sozusagen wie
das langsam so läuft wo das anfängt
außer Kraft genau
und vielleicht das eigentlich geht da
geht's dir kalt den Rücken runter wie
einfach das auch in einer wie ich finde
sehr gefestigten
guten Demokratie wie der deutschen
funktionieren würde aber bevor wir das
machen Richard ich höre raus du hast
dich mit dem Wahlprogramm der AFD
beschäftigt ich habe heute morgen drei
Stunden lang das Wahlprogramm der AFD
studiert ist nicht dein Ernst da steht
übrigens nicht sicher ja
nicht nur lesen sondern auch durch
denken ja also
das hat schon eine normale
Parteiprogramms Länge es gibt nur
Kurzversion und eine lange Version okay
und es unterscheidet sich formal nicht
von den Parteiprogramm der anderen
Parteien
es unterscheidet sich sogar in einigen
inhaltlichen Punkten nicht von manchem
anderen was in manchem anderen Programm
steht
und ich würde es mal also das steht
natürlich nichts von feindlicher
Übernahme drin ne also ist natürlich
nicht im Parteiprogramm der AFD drin
dass man die Pressefreiheit einschränken
will dass man die Gewaltenteilung außer
Kraft setzen will und so weiter
Demokratie theoretisch stehen da
folgende Gedanken drin man möchte mir
direkt die Demokratie
ursprünglich eine linke Forderung
Piratenpartei mehr direkte Demokratie
Volksabstimmung so nach Schweizer Muster
ist ja auch was was in Deutschland auch
seit Jahrzehnten immer wieder diskutiert
wird und zwar unabhängig ob man rechts
oder links ist
Direktwahl des Bundespräsidenten durch
das Volk auch keine echte Forderung ist
auch was was immer wieder aufgekommen
ist ich habe selbst mal lange darüber
nachgedacht ob es eine gute Idee oder
eine schlechte Idee ist also so die
Demokratie ganz kurz in Klammern also
der größte Nachteil wäre der
Bundespräsident hat ja wenig macht also
jemanden direkt vom Volk zu wählen eine
ganze Wahl zu organisieren um jemand in
einen Posten zu bringen der eigentlich
relativ wenig zu sagen hat auch wenn es
formal das Höchste staatsam ist
irgendwie Enttäuschung also wenn man ihn
schon direkt wird müsste ja auch mir
sagen können und jetzt nicht nur so ein
ersatzkönig oder sowas sein
jetzt haben wir den gewählt und das
macht ja nichts ich von den anderen
Punkt wichtiger also mir wäre ja lieb
und das habe ich auch schon ewig gesagt
damals schon als wulff-präsident wurde
mir wäre sehr lieb wenn es kein
Berufspolitiker wäre der Bundespräsident
wird ja sondern wenn das jemand wäre aus
der Zivilgesellschaft der durch
ehrenamtliches Engagement oder andere
große tatenleistungen für die
Gesellschaft positiv aufgefallen ist
einfach jemand der zum Vorbild trägt
genau sich alle irgendwie eingenommen
der aber jetzt nicht so eine
parteipolitische Karriere hinter sich
hat mein Vorwurf war damals 50 Amts müde
ist nicht mehr Ministerpräsident sein
will in Niedersachsen und ich bin
Großburgwedel wohnen will sondern lieber
in Berlin und dann im Schloss Bellevue
sind schlechte Motivation dafür um
Bundespräsident zu werden ich finde es
also viel besser wenn Bundespräsident
jemand zukommen der seine Verdienste
außerhalb der Parteipolitiker geworden
wohnlich zu verbessern natürlich
nachvollziehbar ist ja wenn man das Haus
in Großburgwedel gesehen hat vielleicht
meine jeder hat dann Recht auf ein
selbst verbautes Eigenheim
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
ich habe das gar nicht niemand ist
gezwungen Herr seines eigenen Geschmacks
zu sein ja es war so ein sehr trista
Klinker Baum ich jetzt ich habe eine
Schlagzeile im Kopf da war immer die
Rede von der Klinke Hölle aus
großburgweger genau
aber weiter im Text also afd-programm ja
also im AFD Programm besteht hier steht
jetzt nicht drin die Pressefreiheit zu
beschneiden aber jetzt stellen wir uns
vor die AFD wird stärkste Partei und
regiert es gibt einen Punkt der zum
Thema Medien ja steht da natürlich will
man die GEZ Gebühren abschaffen
und man möchte den öffentlichen
rechtlichen Rundfunk reformieren wobei
der Begriff reformieren sehr freundlich
klingt man will ihn auf etwas ein
Zehntel einschrumpfen das heißt also der
öffentlich-rechtliche Rundfunk soll die
Funktion haben neutral Objektive
Nachrichten zu berichten und über die
eigene Region zu informieren das heißt
es müsste ein ZDF geben für Nachrichten
sind Sendungen und es müsste die
Regionalprogramme der ARD geben für das
regional Fenster und für den Rest
bräuchte man laut AFD kein öffentlich
rechtliche Rundfunk also keine
Fußballspiele mehr übertragen keine
Spielshows machen keine Spielfilme
produzieren
und sagt gerade Haseldorfer auch ja egal
es ist eine Position ja die nicht eins
zu eins nur ja ja
steht aber nichts davon an jetzt einen
der Regierung konform statt
zu installieren und so weiter oder
Propaganda raus zu machen oder so
sondern hier geht es einfach darum der
öffentlich-rechtliche Rundfunk soll über
diese Art und Weise entmachtet und
entpolitisieren werden das heißt ein
Podcast wie unsere käme dann
wahrscheinlich auch nicht mehr vor wir
haben jetzt gerade so fleißig gesagt wir
beide könnten dann auch abgeschafft
werden könnten wir nicht das ist ja
genau der Vorwurf mit dem ich ganz
häufig auch konfrontiert bin dass man
sagt na ja sie müssen ja bestimmt der
Dinge berichten sie müssen ja bestimmte
regierungslinien übernehmen sie kriegen
doch quasi die Themen von der Regierung
vorgegeben und so weiter das ist alles
Quatsch es ist alles Quatsch und auch
ein deutscher Bundeskanzler könnte nicht
hingehen und sagen auch unseren kleinen
unbedeutenden kleinen Podcast hier
könnte der nicht einfach abschaffen und
das ist die Qualität unseres
Rechtsstaats unser Intendant Norbert
Himmler wenn Olaf Scholz dem sagen würde
schaffst du mal das oder jenes ab das
würde ihn dazu bringen ist erst recht
weiter das hätte eine gewisse Gefahr
dass Olaf Scholz sich damit abschafft
ja Verhältnis genau auf jeden Fall genau
die die Vorstellung die die AFD davon
hat wie die Politik den öffentlichen
rechtlichen Rundfunk am Nasenring durch
die Arena führt die ist naiv und dieser
falsch richtig ähm dann ist mir
aufgefallen in der Migrationspolitik
habe ich in der letzten Folge gesagt man
bräuchte wenn man sagt wir müssen die
Grenzen Dichter machen also das bisher
machen einen Plan für Afrika ja also ich
habe gesagt proaktive
Migrationspolitik bräuchten wir ja der
AFD vorgeworfen dass sie die auch nichts
anderes einfällt als abschieben
rausschmeißen Grenzen Dichter machen
notfalls darunter schießen
aber nein im Parteiprogramm steht wir
müssen die Fluchtursachen bekämpfen und
müssen uns in Afrika engagieren steht
tatsächlich in Patte ich weiß nicht ob
es die letzte Woche reingeschrieben
worden ist steht aber im Programm der
AFD so dann habe ich mir das genauer
angeguckt und ist allerdings die
Vorstellung die die AFD von
Fluchtursachen bekämpfen hat merkwürdig
weil es ist immer die Rede von diesem
nicht mehr sehr populären Wort
Entwicklungshilfe sage ich Wort das
nicht mehr als 21 Jahrhundert da gibt's
ja auch nicht mehr aber sie es wird
immer noch so genannt also im
Parteiprogramm wird das noch so genannt
na so nach dem Motto da sind arme Länder
der hungern die Leute dann müssen wir
Entwicklungshilfe machen das nicht so
viele Hunger also es ist sehr sehr unter
Komplex angegangen und dann heißt es
auch wenn wir schon Entwicklungshilfe
geben dann nur in den afrikanischen
Staaten die funktionieren ja wo man weiß
keine Korruption und das versickert
nicht und so weiter ja aber trotzdem
Migranten nicht die Migranten kommen ja
gerade aus den Ländern die nicht
funktionieren wir haben ja kaum
patientenausrufanda hier bei uns was ein
funktionierendes Land ist wir haben viel
mehr die auch Somalia kommen also gerade
hier kaputter ein afrikanisches Land ist
umso größer ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit
dass die Leute daher kommen die tauchen
jetzt in diesem
entwicklungshilfeprogramm der AFD nicht
auf also die wirklich zukunftsweisen den
Dingen wenn wir über Fluchtursachen
reden ja wie wie kann eine Wirtschaft
sich selbst besser organisieren zum
Beispiel einen der einenseitige
Freihandelsabkommen afrikanische Länder
dürfen bei uns Ihre Produkte zollfrei
verkaufen aber Zölle auf unsere Produkte
erheben z.B lange gehegte Forderungen
den ich nicht nachkommen würde zum
Beispiel der afrikanischen Wirtschaft
sehr stark helfen es geht aber noch
viele andere Dinge also wie wir müssten
quasi den Ländern bei der Selbsthilfe
helfen und nicht mit Entwicklungshilfe
ja der damaligen Brunnen bohren und
damals irgendwo anliefern also die
Vorstellung wie Fluchtursachen
Bekämpfung anbelangt da hat man bei der
AFD sehr wenig Wissen über nachgedacht
ich denke gerade noch mal nach über
diesen Satz wie unterstützen nur Länder
die nicht korrupt sind
können wir sozusagen wissen was mit dem
Geld passiert und so weiter das ist ja
ein Satz dann würde ja jeder
unterschreiben ich denke gerade noch mal
so darüber nach ich denke an eine Reise
an mehrere Reisen nach Gambia zum
Beispiel ist das kleinste afrikanische
Land das im Wesentlichen nur aus diesem
Gambia River besteht müssen wir darüber
gesprochen den den die Engländer
behalten haben also rundherum ist ja
Senegal um Gambio mittendrin liegt
dieses kleine Land Gambia besteht
eigentlich nur aus diesem Fluss dort
wird Englisch gesprochen und rundherum
wird französisch gesprochen im Senegal
ja was eine völlig absurde Situation ist
weil man könnte natürlich viel viel
besser Handel treiben und alles besser
miteinander verzahnen wenn alle die
gleiche Sprache sprechen würden aber
nein die die Briten wollten diesen Fluss
warum sie wollten Sklaven raus
transportieren können ist der ganz
traurige Geschichte in den Ufern dieses
Gambia Rivers ganze Dörfer die einfach
leer waren irgendwann wenn man die Leute
auf die Kapverden rüber und dann weiter
nach Amerika verschickt hat grauenvolle
Geschichte aber in
gibt es gibt es eine große Straße ja das
du brauchst auch nicht sehr viel mehr
weil das Land ist eine lange schlanke
Linie sozusagen und diese Straße ist der
Albtraum für jedes Auto egal mit welchem
Auto du da kommst da gibt es
Schlaglöcher die sind so so tief wie bei
uns ganze Häuser hoch sind ja und du
fährst über diese Schlaglöcher und du
kannst die Uhr danach stellen wann das
erste Mal der Reifen platzt oder deine
Achse kaputt ist oder was auch immer das
ist erstmal sozusagen etwas was klingt
wie nach einem Auftrag für die nächste
Reparaturwerkstatt und du sagst na gut
dann verdient er wenigstens ein bisschen
Geld der Schrauber links oder rechts der
Straße aber die Wahrheit ist eine solche
Straße nimmt die Grundgeschwindigkeit
aus einem Land in einer Art und Weise
dass du sagen musst wenn das die
wichtigste Verkehrsader ist dann wird
dieses Land niemals auf die Beine kommen
wenn du alleine die ganzen Lastwagen
denkst die da verrecken dann denkst du
an die Lebensmittel die den singen der
Hitze geladen und dann steht er wieder
darum stundenlang tagelang bis irgendwas
repariert werden kann und dann ist das
Fleisch und alles was da sonst drauf ist
längst verdorben das heißt nur diese
eine Straße wäre sozusagen ein zentrales
Entwicklungsprojekt dass man mal angehen
müsste das hat die EU erkannt irgendwann
und hat angefangen
haben wir auch chinesische Krankenhäuser
und so weiter gesehen das sehr
interessant und dann siehst Du diese
Straße und du weißt die ist mit der
EU-Mitteln zum Teil gefördert worden und
dann siehst Du eigentlich bräuchtest du
was was ich 30 cm her und die
Teerschicht ist aber auf komische Art
und Weise um 20 cm reduziert worden auf
seltsame Art und Weise haben sich 20
Zentimeter Tee einfach aufgelöstigt
verflüssigt und dann sind da halt nur
noch zehn dass die restlichen 20%
umgerechnet in sehr sehr viele Dollars
hat sich irgendjemand einsteckt
allein das diese eine Straße zu
kontrollieren zu überwachen dass das
Geld nicht einfach irgendwo versandet
buchstäblich war nicht möglich kann man
nicht hingekriegt das heißt allein
dieser simple Satz zu sagen es geht mir
nur an Länder die nicht korrupt sind
Wahnsinn wer soll das machen es
funktioniert nicht geht nicht also
gemeint aber nicht durchdacht ja also
das müsste dann Leute haben die das
kontrollieren so wie in Köln wenn deine
U-Bahn gebaut wird dass das nicht die
Eisenträger aus der Wand wieder
rausgenommen werden
ja ja genau hört sich auch was vor
flüssig fehlt dir plötzlich Eisen
bricht
Köln überall auch immer
ja ja natürlich ist das schwierig ne
also mit dem Maßstab zum Essen aber das
das dass das merkwürdige oder das
falsche daran ist diese patriarchische
Form von Entwicklungshilfe die helfen
euch hungern denn da mal so ein bisschen
damit ihr da schön da bleiben können
ein bisschen über den Kopf irgendwie
funktioniert nicht nicht nicht nicht
mehr wie man Zusammenarbeit im 21
Jahrhundert macht ja weil es steht
zumindestens im Parteiprogramm drin so
ein riesen Thema im Parteiprogramm ist
die Europäische Union
also die AFD würde gerne die Europäische
Union auflösen und neu erfinden
und statt der EU möchte sie einen
starken Bund sie sagt wir sind auf dem
Weg in einer europäische Planwirtschaft
oder haben die schon zu einem ziemlich
hohen gerade sehr sehr viele Dinge kann
zum Beispiel der deutsche Landwirt der
übrigens eine große Rolle spielt im
Parteiprogramm also es wird sehr die
ländlichen Regionen sind da sehr stark
repräsentiert
und sagt also dass das alles über den
Kopf des deutschen Landwirts alles
entschieden wird und alles in Brüssel
und die ganzen Kompetenzen die man sich
da angeeignet hat und so weiter das muss
wieder rein nationalisiert werden wir
brauchen einen lockeren Verbund
Europäische Union aber wir können keine
europäische Planwirtschaft machen dafür
sind die Staaten zu unterschiedlich und
dann wird zu viel über die Köpfe der
Menschen hinweg entschieden so da wird
jetzt etwas deutlich was dieses ganze
Programm durchzieht wenn man sagt was
ist der rote Faden der die AFD
zusammenhält dann ist es zu sagen wieder
mehr Autonomie für den Einzeln ja also
mehr in der Region mehr Autonomie dass
ich mehr in meiner Stadt zu sagen habe
in meinem Dorf mehr Autonomie für die
Nationen für Deutschland also weniger
Europa also der der ganze Gedanke ist
wieder zurück zu einem Zustand wo der
einzelne stärker wieder über sich selbst
bestimmen kann das ist das das ist so
der der rote Faden in jedem einzelnen
Punkt des verteilt und da ist auch
dieser Kulturkampf drin ne also diese
sozusagen diese diese Idee da gibt es
diese böse böse verbotspartei die Grünen
das ist das ist der der Feind und die
wollen euch ständig erklären wie ihr zu
leben habt und wir dagegen wollen mit
dieser Gänge lei aufhören ihr lebt
einfach bitte wieder so wie ihr das für
richtig halte richtig genau also nicht
über die Köpfe der Menschen hinweg
entscheiden ja und nicht über
Deutschland hinweg entscheiden also es
gibt so zwei Ebene das eine ist der
Einzelne und sein Dorf und Städte
spielen dann geringere Rolle und das
andere ist Deutschland als Nation und
die beiden auf den beiden Ebenen wieder
mehr Autonomie und das heißt weniger
Autonomie auf die eben Europa ja die
nicht als eigenständige Ebene gesehen
wird ne
und diese diese ganzen fragen ob es
nicht Dinge gibt die man über den Kopf
des Einzelnen hinweg entscheiden muss
weil sie sonst nicht gehen dieses Thema
wird ausgeblendet sondern wenn es um
sowas geht und dann sind wir nachher bei
dem Thema Klima und so weiter und da
wird dann dann bis zum gewissen gerade
einfach auch Tatbestände sagen wir mal
eigenwillig wishful thinking mäßig
interpretiert damit das irgendwie geht
jetzt würde ich gerne mal wissen also
dieser der Gedanke also Auflösung der
Europäischen Union
Fortsetzung als Staatenbund genau das
ist ja sagen wir mal eine der größten
Forderungen der AFD jetzt stell ich mir
die Frage okay wer ist Weidel wird
Bundeskanzlerin oder ein smarter oder
Nachfolger oder Nachfolgerin
Deutschland kann ja die Europäische
Union nicht auflösen aber man könnte
austreten richtig so dann würden dann
würden die anderen das ja auch nicht
alle machen also am nächsten Tag treten
alle anderen auch aus sondern wie die
Europäische Union würde ja bestehen
bleiben also die Deutschland könnte ja
nicht alleine die Europäische Union in
einen Staatenbund überführen nee wir
werden einfach nur draußen
damit ja nicht was Neues geschaffen und
wir können ja auch nichts Neues schaffen
solange die anderen noch bei dem Alten
bleiben
andererseits stellt sich die Frage ob
eine Europäische Union jetzt ohne
England und dann ohne Deutschland und
wenn marien le pennen in Frankreich
Präsidentin wird ohne Frankreich würden
sie wahrscheinlich tatsächlich nicht
bestehen bleiben können also insofern
ist das vielleicht tatsächlich sogar
denkbar dass das passiert
ja und da müsste man sich vorstellen
geht das also kann man ein Gebilde wie
die Europäische Union rückabwickeln es
ist das überhaupt möglich oder also sie
müsste sich beim Überlegen was alles
über Brüssel mittlerweile geregelt wird
das dann alles wieder in nationaler
Kompetenzen und so weiter rein kriegen
und dann kommt die nächste Finanzkrise
und Europa kann nicht mehr handeln und
so also das ist das eine spannende Frage
die mich jetzt rein als Beobachter mal
interessiert ob das überhaupt denkbar
ist dass es geht rein technisch ja und
dass das dann auch irgendwie
funktionieren würde oder ob das
eigentlich gar nicht mehr geht
das ist ja weißt du was was mich gerade
so fasziniert ist die Frage was wäre
wenn du dieses Programm gelesen hättest
ohne zu wissen dass es von der AFD ist
so wie du das nicht also ich habe also
das Bild was ich von der AFD im Kopf
habe ist natürlich wesentlich vom
politischen Personal der AFD trägt ja
und ich weiß dass es mit dem Kalbitz der
jetzt keine große Funktion mehr hat und
mit Björn höcke nun wirklich man kann ja
sagen wir kennen den Nazis ja also
keinen großen hier daraus machen möchten
dass die Nazis sind und die sich in der
deutschen Geschichte
schmutzig die den Holocaust relativieren
die die Verbrechen der deutschen
Wehrmacht zu zu notwehrreaktionen
erklären muss und so weiter und so
weiter ja und von einer tausendjährigen
deutschen Geschichte auf deutschen
Marktplätzen predigen in der es
irgendwie keine Zäsur gegeben hat und
von wegen wir Deutschen wir sind auch
nicht schlechter als die anderen und so
diese ganzen Sachen also alles ich bin
sehr sensibel was weil alles was sie
Verbrechen des Nationalsozialismus
anbelangt so das prägt natürlich mein
Bild von der AFD und auch diese habe ich
ja schon mal gesagt die aggressive
Rhetorik ist nicht ne also dass man
immer sagt das wollen wir nicht das
wollen wir nicht das wollen wir nicht
und relativ wenig in den Debatten kommt
was man so konstruktiv für
Gegenvorschläge zu machen hat das stört
mich auch und auch so eine Sonne Sonne
Schafe manchmal ins hysterische
gleitende Rhetorik so und das ist
natürlich alles was man emotionales Bild
von AFD prägt und für mich ist natürlich
aufgrund auch meiner Sozialisation alles
wo das Wort rechts drauf steht zunächst
mal mit äußerst davor sich zu genießen
wenn ich jetzt aber nur das
Parteiprogramm lese dann würde ich jetzt
nicht sagen das klingt auf mich
wahnsinnig rechts ne also Nazi schon mal
gar nicht da ist nichts rassistisches in
irgendeiner Form drin was da die
natürlich dieses klare Kante zeigen in
der Migrationspolitik ehrlich gesagt
es ist der Unterschied zu dem was die
CDU praktizieren würde oder was was
viele Leute in Deutschland inzwischen
für richtig halten also Verschärfung des
Asylrechts
straffällig gewordene Menschen mit
Migrationshintergrund so schnell wie
möglich abschieben und sowas ich meine
ich will nicht wissen wie viel Prozent
der Bevölkerung die nicht AFD wählen das
genauso sehen da steht aber nichts drin
von wegen Leute aus dem arabischen
Kulturkreis sind irgendwie rassistischen
minderwertig und sollen sich hier nicht
mit arischen Blut vermischen oder sowas
das so steht so ich würde das
wahrscheinlich Klingen werden höcke das
Programm geschrieben hat der ist sicher
nicht geschrieben hat vielleicht
reingeguckt hat also so das
Parteiprogramm selber ist viel
unschuldiger als das Personal ist
richtig und ich weiß nicht unter da
kommen wir wieder sozusagen zu dem Punkt
an dem es was es ist immer so bequem zu
sagen und und das gilt für uns alle uns
Medien auch ausdrücklich mit
angeschlossen es ist so bequem zu sagen
guck mal die da was die da machen und
igitt wie kann man nur und dann endet es
dann manchmal auch noch in wählerbe
schimpfung da habe ich das Gefühl dass
endet jetzt langsam wird da findet dann
Umdenken statt aber sich stattdessen
sozusagen mit guter Politik zu
profilieren und zu überlegen okay wie
könnte denn unsere politische Antwort
darauf Aussehen statt sich ständig über
die AFD zu echauffieren ja und darüber
aufzuregen was sie jetzt was da wieder
und dort wieder und so weiter
also heißt mit anderen Worten über jedes
Stöckchen ständig drüber zu springen
dass die uns hinhalten ja statt einfach
zu sagen weißt du was wir lass die
machen aber wir machen unser Ding die
AFD Punkte vor allen Dingen in den
ländlichen Regionen und vor allem im
Osten damit dass sie sagt wir kümmern
uns um eure Belange und wir hören euch
zu ja so und da sind die anderen
Parteien offensichtlich nicht besonders
gut darin das zu tun
richtig ist es denn nicht richtig dass
viele europäische Regelungen bis viel zu
tief in die regionale Ebene hineingehen
brauchen wir nicht viel mehr regionale
Autonomie müsste es nicht viel mehr
Dinge geben die die Leute in ihrem
Landkreis oder in ihrer Stadt selbst
bestimmen können ohne das gleich wieder
irgendwelche Direktiven Richtlinien
Vorschriften und so weiter das unmöglich
machen also ist das nicht etwas wo die
AFD etwas sozusagen eine Unzufriedenheit
abschöpft ja die die sie nur deswegen
abschöpfen kann weil sie von den anderen
Parteien nicht ernst genug genommen wird
also müssen sich nicht überlegen dass
sie da vielleicht nicht auch eine Menge
falsch gemacht haben und da nicht genau
hingehört haben genau was ich will sagen
Dinge haben sich häufig so
verselbstständigt schlicht und
ergreifend und das ist dann da Zeit
gelegentlich mal die Frage zu stellen
muss das eigentlich so sein lass uns ein
anderes ganz konkretes Beispiel nehmen
das Leben ist ja immer dann besonders
interessant wenn es ganz handfest und
konkret wird wie oft habe ich bei mir
Leute sitzen die sagen fliegen ist nicht
mehr Autofahren ist nicht mehr
Verbrenner sowieso nicht das geht so
alles nicht weiter wir ÖPNV öffentliche
Verkehrsmittel ja stimmt das Leuten auf
dem Land sagst dann lachen die dich aus
und ich habe dieser Tage eine Zahl
gelesen die mir klar gemacht hat warum
die dich auslachen wenn du auf dem Land
lebst und öffentliche Verkehrsmittel
nimmst oder öffentlich rechtliche
Verkehrsmittel nimmst wie Claudia
Pechstein sagen würde dann hast du das
Problem dass du dreimal so lang
unterwegs bist wie mit deiner eigenen
Karre im Schnitt dreimal so lang das
heißt so schlecht funktioniert dieses
System
dass das Leute als Gängelung empfinden
wenn man ihn dann trotzdem ständig sagt
ist egal und deine Zeit ist mir auch
egal aber du bitte nimmst jetzt auf
Teufel komm raus den Bus die Bahn den
ich fährt und was auch immer das
verstehe ich total und deswegen wäre
doch die kluge politisch Antwort darauf
zu sagen pass auf weißt du was ich habe
dich verstanden ihr habt ein Problem
dass uns dafür sorgen dass es
funktioniert schlicht und ergreifend und
diese Liste an Beispielen ist unendlich
lang und ich ja ich habe dieser Tage mal
wieder mit einem Landrat in dem Fall was
er Henning Haus Thüringen in der
dienstälteste Landrat Deutschlands zu
tun gehabt gesprochen den ich wahnsinnig
mag das dann ein ein ganz integerer
aufrichtiger Grund anständiger Mann so
dieses im besten Sinne dieses gute alte
Deutschland das ist mal gab dafür steht
dieser Mann für mich und ich ich sehe
den ich höre wie der redet ich guckte
mir die Augen und ich vertraue dem ich
weiß bei diesem Mann ist das Land in
guten Händen und ich hatte in den
letzten Monaten so viel mit Landräten zu
tun und eine andere ist zum Beispiel
Tanja Schweiger und das Hunter Weise die
Lebensgefährtin von von Hubert alwagern
die Landrätin in Regensburg ist ähnlich
gar nicht ideologisch sondern jemand der
ganz handfest sagt was auf ihr sagt mir
an ich muss jetzt hier Leute
unterbringen ich muss die Schulen
organisieren ich mache das ganz
unprätentiös ganz unaufgeregt aber ganz
handfest und sehr zupackend die machen
das einfach und da ist mir klar geworden
und da kriegt man so ein bisschen den
Glauben machen dieses Land zurück es
gibt in diesem Land an der Basis
Landräte Landrätinnen unglaublich gute
Leute und wir sollten den viel mehr noch
sozusagen Kompetenz und auch macht in
die Hand geben weil die wissen wie es
geht ja und die sind richtig richtig gut
ich habe keinen einzigen durchgeknallten
dabei erlebt so der der so weißt du so
so komische Anwandlungen hat so ich bin
hier nur so patriarchalisch von oben
nach ich weiß wie es geht sondern ganz
demütig Leute die ganz handfest ihre
Arbeit machen ja und und von denen haben
wir viele und die sollten wir viel mehr
nutzen ja und das geht auch für die
Bildung Bildungspolitik wir sollten
Lehrer und Schuldirektoren und so weiter
viel mehr Möglichkeiten geben zusammen
mit Eltern ihre Schulen in bestimmte
Richtung zu entwickeln wer
Gestaltungsfreiheit selber darüber zu
entscheiden ob es im Sportunterricht in
der Grundschule Noten verteilen wollen
oder nicht also die Leine zu lösen und
dann haben wir Institutionen Gängen wie
die Schulen oder in denen in das das
sehr sehr enge rechts Korsett ja dass
die Gestaltungsmöglichkeiten und
problemlösungsmöglichkeiten auf auf
Ebene von Landkreisen und Kommunen und
so weiter einschränkt also darüber
denken wir viel zu wenig nach ja warum
kann man nicht diese diesen legitimen
Gedanken die mehr Autonomie ja wieso
kann man den nicht
produktiv gestalten warum muss man die
Menschen die das Bedürfnis haben der AFD
zutreiben also diese Tage müssen sich
die etablierten Parteien ganz deutlich
stellen dazu beklagen dass sie dann dort
hingehen ja das ist genau der Punkt und
wenn man wenn man das sich mal alles so
anschaut dann kriegt man irgendwann eine
Idee davon was es möglicherweise ist
dass die Leute gerade im Moment in die
Arme dieser dieser wirklich zum Teil
sind wirklich übel Rattenfänger treibt
aber interessant auch daher Henning ne
deswegen war dieses Gespräch so Gold
wert der sagt ne die reine Leere in
Berlin ist da gibt es diese harte
Brandmauer und so weiter und mit keiner
Zusammenarbeit mit der AFD und die klare
Kante und so weiter und ich verstehe das
weil die die Bundestagsabgeordneten die
da jeden Tag im Parlament sitzen die
kriegen häufig auch unbemerkt von
Mikrofonen und Kameras die kriegen Dinge
mit die dort in diesem Deutschen
Bundestag mittlerweile gerufen werden
die den zugerannt werden und so weiter
das ist ekelhaft und ich verstehe dass
die zum Teil mit den Leuten die da
sitzen nichts mehr zu tun haben haben
wollen selbst wenn Sie guten Willen sind
aber dann sagt herr Henning wieder
verstehe ich aber in meinem Landkreis ja
ist es völlig völlig illusorisch nicht
mit denen auf der einen oder anderen
Ebene Absprachen zu treffen so
kooperieren und so weiter ich brauche
die wenn ich bestimmte Dinge umsetzen
will und er sagte auch wenn das jetzt
keiner hören will aber im Land meinem
Landkreis gibt es den ein oder anderen
von der AFD das sind durchaus
vernünftige Leute also mehr Pragmatismus
und ich würde mal sagen jemand wie herr
Henning ist einer dem können wir die
Entscheidung darüber und das Urteil
darüber ob man mit dem arbeiten kann um
mit der anderen vielleicht nicht das
können wir ruhig ein Handy überlassen
der weiß schon was gut ist der macht das
aus nicht aus Berlin gesagt genau ja es
gibt noch zwei Punkte im Parteiprogramm
ist Bildungspolitik das ist der
langweiligste Punkt im Parteiprogramm
was haben sie davor alles wieder wie
früher
was heißt das ja also drei gliedriges
System keine Gesamtschulen keine
Schulexperimente wieder wieder
Fachwissen statt Kompetenzen und was ich
alles so verändert hat also im Grunde
genommen wieder lasst uns Schulen machen
wie den 60er 70er Jahren das heißt auch
inklusive in der Ecke stehen oder auch
mal eine Backpfeife
das ist das das assoziere ich zwar damit
aber man muss sagen steht nicht im
Parteiprogramm der Rohstoffe und nicht
wieder eingeführt aber im Grunde
genommen ist es sowie die gute alte
Schule mal waren die ich besucht habe
und die suchen
außerdem darf man nicht vergessen dass
diese Schule gemacht war ja für die
Lohnarbeit Gesellschaft des 20
Jahrhunderts und nicht gemacht ist für
die
beruflichen Herausforderung vor dem man
heute steht 21 Jahrhundert und deswegen
muss Schule sich verändern und deswegen
kann ich mit diesem gesamten Abschnitt
überhaupt gar nichts anfangen also es
wird so als hätte man sich keine
ernsthaften Gedanken gemacht sondern nur
gesagt alles was neumodisch dazu
gekommen ist war irgendwie blöd und
jetzt lass uns das machen wie früher
also ganz schwacher Link im Programm und
dann gibt es noch den Programm Außen-
und Sicherheitspolitik da hattest du ja
propalla da zu zu befragt also die die
die Grundausrichtung des Programms sagt
Deutschland muss wieder autonomer in der
Welt werden da haben wir wieder die
Autonomie Sache also wir müssen quasi
raus aus dem starken Windschatten der
USA wir brauchen ein eigenständiges
Europa und innerhalb dieses
eigenständigen Europas eigenständige
Nationalstaaten also die AFD hält nichts
von einer europäischen Armee also
wahrscheinlich nicht dass irgendwie ein
griechischer general über deutsche
Offiziere befehligt sondern sie möchte
vielleicht aber schon umgekehrt
also Unterführung Deutschlands
vielleicht steht aber nicht im Programm
aber dieser dieser Gedanke quasi also
die Verteidigung Souveränität Autonomie
ist ganz wichtig ja deswegen natürlich
Aufrüstung der Bundeswehr
Verteidigungsbereitschaft aber eben
keine Außenpolitik mehr unter dem
Stichwort Westen also was ja sehr häufig
eben bedeutet sich mit den
amerikanischen Interessen gleich zu
machen sondern ein eigenständigen Weg zu
gehen und wir und dann steht darin wir
brauchen ein gutes Verhältnis zu den USA
und irgendwann wieder auch zu Russland
gegen diesen Satz ja ich nicht nee ja
weil das wäre das tatsächlich irgendwann
brauchen wann auch immer das möglich ist
ist völlig klar wir können nicht
dauerhaft wieder in einen kalten Krieg
und können im 21 Jahrhundert dem
Zeitalter des Klimawandels und und der
großen migrationsbewegung und so weiter
wieder wieder Kalten Krieg spielen die
im 20 Jahrhundert das ist schon richtig
gut jetzt kann man sagen hier stehen
keine Lösungen da drin wie man das
machen soll das ist auch nicht die
Aufgabe eines Partei Programms aber das
ist die Frage vor der eine Regierung
dann stünde genau also wie sehe das denn
ganz ganz konkret aus genau also was was
würde aus der NATO unter solche
Umständen zum Beispiel ja und dann der
Teil des Parteiprogramms der für mich
ein Ausflug nach Absurdistan ist das ist
alles was mit Klima Energiepolitik und
so weiter zu tun hat also da macht man
es sich wirklich wahnsinnig einfach
wishful thinking ja der Klimawandel ist
nicht von Menschen gemacht den
Klimawandel gibt es den kann man wohl
inzwischen auch in der AFD nicht mehr
bestreiten dass er irgendwie existiert
aber ist natürlich oder soll natürlich
sein und jetzt besteht die große
Herausforderung an diese positive Chance
zu gewöhnen weil so im Parteiprogramm
der AFD Wärmeperioden auf dem Planeten
immer viel fruchtbarer und besser für
das Leben waren als Kälteperiode können
wir uns eigentlich auf gesegnete Zeiten
einstellen das müssen wir nur machen
also wenn man Klimawandel erfahren diese
diesen Teil des Parteiprogramms von den
Gebrüdern Grimm geschrieben ja ist also
so ein dermaßen es hoffen alles wird gut
wenn wir uns nur richtig anstrengen
angesichts einer Problematik die ganz
ernsthaft dabei ist alles zu zerstören
was auf diesem Planeten
das Leben für den Menschen noch
lebenswert oder lebensmöglich macht da
stellt man sich die Frage wie kann im 21
Jahrhundert eine Partei die sich
demokratische Partei nennt und die
irgendwann mal Mehrheitspartei werden
will so einen Unfug in ihr Programm
bescheid sagen die Quintessenz ist die
kühlen Tage werden weniger ja wir können
öfter und länger draußen sitzen auch mal
bis in den Spätherbst hinein ja also
dass das heißt Richard mit anderen
Worten dieses Programm ist ja eigentlich
so wie es der herkommt und das ist auch
genau das was ich so beobachte das ist
harmlos und das ist auch genauso
intendiert es soll keine Leute genauso
aussehen wie genau drei Programme
anderer Parteien genau
demokratische Partei unter anderem genau
das heißt dass das ist Wolf im
Schafspelz kann man nicht anders sagen
wenn man das Personal kennt der AFD ja
ja vorhin gesprochen haben ja dann
kriegt man das Parteiprogramm auf der
einen Seite und das Personal auf der
anderen Seite erstmal überhaupt gar
nicht zusammen genau und dann wird einem
Zweifelsfall
davon ausgehen dass eine regierende AFD
das einlöst was ihr handelndes Personal
verspricht als das was im Parteiprogramm
steht ja und die das wahre
Parteiprogramm ist eigentlich ein
anderes das wahre Parteiprogramm der AFD
ist das Spiel mit der Angst ja genau
rese und die Maus ja obwohl dieser
berühmte satzner von gauland ist kein
Programm aber face und Timo ist
mittlerweile Programm
ist ein riesen Erfolgsprogramm wenn man
die reden hört und so weiter dann hat
man trotz da hat er sich genau Angst und
wir sind keine Mitläufer ja sondern wir
sind die einzigen die klar denken also
mehr als jeder andere Partei schmeichelt
die AFD ihren Wählern damit ja indem sie
jeden zu einem genieverkehrt ja indem
sie sagt du ne was du den deinem Kopf
sich da abspielt von wegen nieder in
Berlin und so weiter du denkst genau
richtig
und das kann man also meisterhaft machen
erst vorbereitet man eine riesige Angst
und dann erzählt man im Zweifelsfall
jedem Volltrottel am Ende noch dass er
genau alles richtig erkannt hat die
spannende Frage wäre dann tatsächlich
wenn es um Lösungen ginge ja aber das
scheint die Wähler nicht zu
interessieren Lösung interessiert wenn
Angst dein Geschäft ist dann brauchst du
keine genau mit ja das ist der Punkt und
die AFD ist nicht eine Partei wie andere
Parteien das muss man einfach mal ganz
ganz deutlich sagen und das Bild vom
Wolf im Schafspelz ist da möglicherweise
schon noch genau das Richtige und ich
habe dieser Tage sehr interessantes
Interview gelesen mit Nora Markert ich
weiß nicht du kennst die möglicherweise
Professoren für Verfassungsrecht an der
Uni Münster die gefragt worden ist wenn
du jetzt mal das gedanklich mal
durchspielst angenommen und da steht es
plötzlich eine AFD Bundeskanzlerin oder
dann AFD Kanzler wie leicht wäre es auch
in einer Demokratie wieder unseren die
regelt sie zu verändern das ist die
spannende Frage genau und Frau Makart
sagt ich ich nenn mal ein paar ja sagt
da bieten sich Möglichkeiten es beginnt
zum Beispiel damit dass die AFD wo sie
dann die Kontrolle über die Exekutive
erregt ja da kann sie dann Beamte
ernennen die dauerhaft bleiben du kannst
bei der Polizei das machen du kannst das
in den Schulen machen du kannst das eben
Jobcenter machen du kannst das in der
Ausländerbehörde machen und da kannst
das in der Staatsanwaltschaft machen so
ne also da hast du schon mal so das eine
Thema und sie sagt die erste Station für
so eine Umgestaltung und das siehst Du
zum Beispiel den Polen und den Ungarn
ist das entscheidende Schritt ist die
Umgestaltung der Justiz ja das hast du
auch in der Türkei gesehen dass das
Brasilien gesehen also autoritäre
Politiker fangen genau da an muss man
sagen Gerichte Justiz ist ja sie benutzt
das so als Begriff
politikwissenschaftlich gesehen ist
quasi eine Art der vetospieler in einer
Demokratie also wenn wenn
Politiker irgendwas wollen und so weiter
dann kann unabhängiges starkes Gericht
immer sagen genau das widerspricht der
Verfassung autoritäre Richtung geht ja
das wollen wir nicht aber wenn es zum
Beispiel jetzt anschaust die AFD die
kommt jetzt an die Macht wie würde die
Vorgehen dann sagt sie ein Mittel zum
Beispiel in Polen war dass man einfach
eine neue niedrige Altersgrenze für
Richter eingeführt hat ne das klingt
erstmal politisch so unverdächtig aber
das bedeutet dass auf einen Schlag und
da wird nämlich dann spannend ganz viele
Richterinnen und auch Richter er
pensioniert werden und die Regierung hat
plötzlich die Chance die Justiz
sozusagen mit ihren Leuten
Donald Trump war wo der Präsident da am
Ende entscheidet wer da in dieses
Oberste Verfassungsgericht da reingeht
ist das eigentlich auch so es ist auch
so ja da habe ich mich auch gewundert
amerikanische Präsident Vollmacht hat ja
es gibt noch einen anderen
und das geht aber bei uns auch und das
ist sozusagen die die schockierende
Erkenntnis daran der andere Trick wäre
zum Beispiel Gerichte zu vergrößern ne
du sagst und der wird auch keiner
meckern da würde man sagen ah die sind
ja eh alle überlastet und so weiter und
es gibt ja eh die Klage über die
riesigen Aktenberge und so weiter und
dann schafft man einfach und verkauft
das noch als groß Tat in der Politik als
30% mehr Richter stellen so und diese
neuen
[Musik]
jobsänger ja interessant ist wenn du dir
zum Beispiel mal klar machst wie in
Deutschland Richter ausgewählt werden ne
den meisten Bundesländern machen das
sogenannte Richter Wahlausschüsse ja da
haben dann die Abgeordneten und damit
die Parteien und in dem Fall wäre es
dann die AFD viel mit Sprache ja das
sollte eine gewisse demokratische
Legitimation herstellen und so weiter
und bisher was immer so man jetzt
versucht das möglichst unabhängig zu
halten was in der gelebten Wirklichkeit
bedeutet da gibt es so ein
demokratischen sonst kann man Sense ja
so eine so eine so ein so ein
basiskonsens man sagt wir streben bei
der Wahl von Richtern so ein Gewissen
Konsens an ja also wer politisch in der
Mehrheit ist geht trotzdem fair um mit
dem was die Minderheit will was die
Opposition will bei allen klar ist ich
selber könnte übermorgen ja auch
plötzlich wieder die Opposition oder die
Minderheit sein das musst du aber nicht
so machen das machen Demokraten
untereinander so das kannst du aber auch
ganz anders machen also jetzt würde die
AFD das sofort kontern und würde sagen
mit ihr als Opposition geht auch kein
Affäre um ja dann werden weil ihr
nämlich keine demokratene Seite nach den
Spielregeln die wir uns unter Demokratie
vorstellen und dann würde die AFD wieder
sagen wer bestimmt denn was die
schwierigen sind für gute Demokraten
sind ja ja das ist der Punkt wo sich das
Ganze immer im Kreise dreht genau ich
will nur sagen die Justiz ist quasi das
sagt einfach so eine offene Flanke
unserer Demokratie das ist sehr
verwundbar und das haben wir in der
Weimarer Republik schon mal gesehen ja
dass auch da zum Beispiel Juristen die
keine
glühenden Faschisten waren die haben
sich dann einfach zurückgezogen also
passt auf die bequeme Behauptung und
haben gesagt eine bitte also wir wenden
ja nur neutral das Recht an das Politik
oder Parlament ist sozusagen macht und
genau und wir wollen noch keinen Streit
mit dieser neuen Regierung und so weiter
das heißt sie haben rein Weise von sich
aus plötzlich darauf verzichtet dieses
Vito dass ihn eigentlich zusteht hart
einzulegen und hat auszuspielen das
persönliche Risiko ebenso groß
erschienen genau also die die
schreckliche Quintessenz darunter ist
dass Menschen sehr sehr anpassungsfähig
sind ja und dass ich in dem Moment wo
man massive Unannehmlichkeiten für seine
politische Position zu fürchten hat die
Leute sehr geschmeidig ihre Moral
verändern genau ich glaube das ist eine
zeitlose Erkenntnis das geht in jedem
Land der Welt zu jeder Zeit es gibt ja
es gibt übrigens auch bei uns in in
Hessen hat ein Richter unlängst
ausgeführt dass die npd-parole Migration
tötet korrekt sei
der war gleichzeitig am
Verwaltungsgericht für Asyl zuständig
und in Sachsen
meist Frau Marker daraufhin ist in ist
gerade ein Richter aufgefallen der
asylkritische Texte in der
rechtsradikalen Jungen Freiheit schreibt
so
also ich will nur sagen da merkst du da
da bröckelt was ja geht ganz schnell
und das ist so der Punkt dass man dass
man im Grunde sich darüber im Klaren
sein muss unser ganzes System diese
ganze Demokratie
sehr sehr fragil das geht und das geht
schneller obwohl sie ja geschaffen wurde
genau
das ist eigentlich auf Ewigkeitswert
gestellt das war der Gedanke ne das
sollte eine liberale Demokratie sein und
die sollte sich nicht wieder Weimarer
Republik von ihnen selbst aushebeln
können deswegen hat man zum Beispiel den
Bundespräsidenten so wenig Macht
verdient anders als der Reichspräsident
in der Weimarer Republik der
enorme Kompetenzen gehabt hat dann hat
man gesagt nee das machen wir in
Deutschland mal besser nicht ja mit
Macht geben dem nicht so viel Macht wie
Russland seinem Präsidenten oder die
Ukraine sein ihrem Präsidenten oder die
Amerikaner ihrem Präsidenten sondern der
der Präsident kriegt relativ wenig Macht
wir haben die fünf Prozent Hürde
eingeführt weil wir damit kleinen
radikalen Parteien nicht die Möglichkeit
geben wollten ins Parlament zu kommen
und damit zu mischen und größer zu
werden wollten auch eine verhindern dass
es zu viele Parteien gibt weil Mal gab
es ja sehr viele Parteien als lauter
verschiedene Interessensvertretungen
mittlerweile muss man sich überlegen
damals gab es drei Parteien CDU also CSU
auch also cdu/csu als Fraktion und SPD
und FDP dann kamen die Grünen dazu in
Linkspartei die AFD also wir vermehren
ja im Augenblick auch die Parteien und
das kann ja sein wenn Sarah Wagenknecht
der Partei Gründe das noch eine dazu
kommt und vielleicht trennen sich ja
irgendwann die Grünen mal voneinander in
die Hardcore grün und die Softcore grün
dann vielleicht mal noch eine Partei
mehr also das ändert sich ja alles
sowieso wir müssen gerade feststellen
dass ein System was wir auf Ewigkeit
gestellt haben und wo ich in meiner
Kindheit Jugend und Sozialisation auch
gedacht habe da bleibt jetzt immer so
genau wirklich auf ewig so genau nichts
bleibt auf ewig es bleibt nichts wie sie
ist und nicht haben wir gerade über die
Justiz gesprochen wie schnell das geht
das ist genauso in Polen und den Ungarn
passiert und und dann hättest du
sozusagen noch den letzten Hebel wo du
ganz unmittelbar einfach ansetzen kannst
ne autoritäre interessieren sich immer
für den Zugriff auf die Medien ne und in
Deutschland haben wir schon gesprochen
gibt's hier Rundfunkgeräte die ARD und
ZDF zum Beispiel kontrollieren die sind
politisch besetzt und alle
gesellschaftlichen Gruppen repräsentiert
und so weiter ja Politiker dürfen
maximal ein Drittel stellen ist auch
ganz interessant ja das sind aber häufig
die Wortführer weil sie oft versierter
sind also die Vertreter von von manchen
Verbänden ja also gegen sie
professionell kaum eine Chance haben
genau und was interessant ist welche
Gruppen da in diesen rund konkreten also
als Vertreter der Zivilgesellschaft
entsandt werden das entscheidet der
Gesetzgeber das entscheidet die
Regierungsmehrheit und das heißt auch
das könnte eine autoritäre Mehrheit ja
das ist überhaupt grundsätzlich schon
keine gute Idee genau
rechtzeitig reformiert ja könnt ihr die
Gewichte verschieben und könnte sich
dann viel viel härter beim
öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk
beispielsweise einmischen und man würde
auch da Leute finden so wie du das bei
den Juristen geschrieben hast die sich
im Zweifelsfall anpassen würden
könnte man sagen wir könnten ja sagen da
dürfen keine Extremisten rein und das
wiederum was extremistisch ist legt der
Verfassungsschutz fest ja aber der
Verfassungsschutz ist auch eine Behörde
ja und die Weisung diese Behörde Jahre
lange geführt Georg Maaßen ja also die
jetzt nicht als die Mitte der
Gesellschaft betrachten ja und die den
Weisungen des Innenministeriums
unterliegen ist und so weiter die
führende Banken werden dann vom
Innenministerium oder irgendwie sowas
oder von Ausschüssen oder so besetzt
also da hast du ja genau die selben
Situation die Macht übernimmt dann würde
sie dort vom Verfassungsschutz
wahrscheinlich nicht mehr als
rechtsextrem eingestuft werden das ist
das erste wovon die wo die sofort den
Stecker ziehen würden 100%ig ja das
genau das was passieren würde ja
deswegen ist interessant aber ich
Hans-Georg Maaßen übrigens auch ganz
interessant als Jurist klug ne der hat
der hat nie sozusagen Verbote angestrebt
weder von rechten Parteien noch von
linken Parteien weil ihm klar war wie
schwer das ist ne das ist ja dann
gründest du dich unter anderem Namen
wieder neu also das ist überhaupt nicht
funktioniert also diese Parteien
verbieten es ist überhaupt kein richtig
Volksgeschichte nee ist zweimal
funktioniert ne zweimal funktioniert
einmal mit der
nachfolgeparteien Ende der 50er Jahre
die KPD verboten genau
gegründet ja ja genau ja und die für
jede rechte Partei jede Nazi-Partei die
man irgendwann mal ich glaube das sind
ja auch mal zwischen die NPD
funktioniert
und so weiter also mit Partei verboten
lässt sich da gar nichts machen sondern
die die Lösung besteht darin jenen
Leuten die jetzt nicht also
verrot sind ja und und an ihre in ihrer
Seele verdorben dass sie meinen Zuflucht
zu fassen waren und Nazis unserem ganzen
braunen Mister zu suchen sondern die
sich einfach die sich auch ärgern dass
der Bus nicht fährt und das von mir aus
die Wölfe da sind und dass sie nicht
gefragt werden der Frage ob da Migranten
wie und wo wohnen und so weiter und
denen man nichts anbieten kann was man
langfristig in den Blick auf
einwanderungs- und Zuwanderungspolitik
konstruktives vor hat und und und die
auch so einer Motivation herausragen
jetzt reicht mir die da in Berlin die
kriegen ja nichts auf die Kette ich will
jetzt AFD die muss man wieder abholen
und zwar nicht indem man Restaurants
bedient sondern indem man hilft Ihnen
hilft Ihre Probleme mit dem Bus der dann
noch wirklich fährt
ich danke dir so interessant Austausch
ja ich danke dir auch spannend jetzt
kann ich endlich meinen dir das AFD
Programm gelesen hat ich bin ich ich
werde würde gerne mal wissen wie viele
AFD Wähler das gelesen haben ja in der
Tat also
hat eine gute Woche danke sehr Tschüss
bis bald
[Musik]
bei OMR im Auftrag des ZDF